that we uh never lost our belief in the
fact that we had a chance to win that
game uh even down two scores just
continuing to fight fight for each other
uh and like i said when is the team lose
the team but you know i can't turn the
ball over and put some positions you
know where they have easy points from
the one yard line you know it's that's
not our defense's fault but that's
that's my
baker mayfield great performance last
night great performance against the
tennessee titans he's
developing and maturing before our eyes
that's good news for the cleveland
browns bad news is they lost the game
but the good news is baker mayfield is
becoming the guy that many have wondered
is he
going to be that guy is he the right guy
for the cleveland browns to take them
where they want to be could it be they
have all the right pieces in place
except a quarterback who is in that
upper echelon it it and i'm not ready to
say he's in the upper echelon
but he's moving that way he's trying
something's happened right yeah this
this four months of influence of kevin
stefanski is starting to pay off and
push him in that direction and
that could be very good news for the
browns obviously if he becomes that guy
that means you don't have to go try to
find somebody else who will become the
guy right not everybody just walks in
the league and it's patrick mahomes or
you know aaron rodgers when they take
over and they just become the guy not
everybody does that you know hey
the guy that we consider the guy of guys
you know he won three super bowls you
know kind of handing the ball off
defense ooh make a big throw tom brady
and then it evolved it evolved and then
he could carry the team and then it was
like oh man brady's here he's gonna
carry it and we're okay no matter who we
got on the team you know baker mayfield
can become that either way you're right
i mean we're watching him evolve and and
mature right in front of our face and
two you know i think was one thing that
just gets glossed over with him it is it
is three offenses you know he's had a
had a play through in his nfl career
that's not easy and you know his first
two offenses in the nfl and also leading
back to oklahoma were just pass pass
pass pass fast pass pass pass don't ever
think about managing a game just keep
throwing it who cares who cares who
cares if he's open great if he's in if
you throw an interception who cares
we'll come back and throw it again and
he's had to learn to play a different
style and as we see he's really learned
to adjust and play the right way and the
offensive system fits him in everything
and he was he was great last night i
mean so many big time throws uh yeah the
interception happened that's gonna
happen in football it's not a perfect
sport but what we loved is the way he
answered back answered back and they
like took momentum back at the football
game where you went whoa they're they're
not going to lose this you know you
almost had that feeling like they're
just not going to be stopped tonight so
a lot to like about what cleveland and
baker mayfield did
something about baker mayfield that i
had considered in the past but it
crystallized just now as you were
explaining what he's doing
it has to be so difficult for him to
come out of the big 12 and see what
rivals and teammates
in that conference have done in the nfl
like patrick mahomes from texas tech
right kyler murray who succeeded baker
mayfield at oklahoma these guys come in
and take the nfl by storm right he
doesn't instead of trying to be them and
to fast forward to he doesn't instead of
trying to be them and to fast forward to
where they are i think at some level
he's accepted just have to be the best
me i can be i'm not going to be patrick
mahomes he's not going to be me i have
to be the best baker mayfield i can be
and get the most out of my skill sets
whatever they may be they're different
than patrick's they're different than
kyler's right i just have to focus on me
and hope the success comes but that has
to be i mean you think about that guys
you know definitely guys that you were
better than
in college are now better than you
that's going to create a weird sense of
urgency and almost panic where am i
where is my career going why are they
great not that it's something you're
going to talk openly about but at some
point in the quiet moments chris you
know that's rattling around inside of
him where he sees these guys having wild
success and he's still kind of spinning
in the mud yeah well manicured field you
you you can you can press
you want it you want your success now
you believe you're every bit as good as
those other guys or at least close to it
you know i hey you're naturally like
that with just the other quarterbacks in
your draft class let alone guys you had
rival rivalries with in college and know
personally and do those things but you
know i used to sit there with guys that
i was driving if i knew i was going to
play them or was coming up on the
schedule i mean i had i had a circle
oh
oh we might play rex grossman i'm going
to show rex grossman who should have
been drafted first
i mean that's what i i really thought
kyle bowler i'm going to show him well
hey his bar was higher than mine i know
that he played the super bowl i didn't
so
i'll take rex grossman's career and
money if he wants we can switch all
right but i i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
give you i'm not gonna give you many
complaints in my life
compliments in my lifetime but uh and
there it is but if you had been if you
had been the starting quarterback of the
bears in 2006 and had kept your spleen
you would have played in the super bowl
too well thank you i'd like to think
that too i don't know that but you know
hey i had my chance and it is what it is
but to your point yes when it comes to
that type of stuff it is on the radar of
the quarterback and you know he's he's
you said it a few weeks ago
he has shown maturity on the field he
has shown maturity
in his interviews and the way he's
handled himself this year too
so i think he's turned the corner in all
areas as has the franchise of the
cleveland browns and what stefanski's
done there and everything i mean
gosh they closed the gap significantly
from where it was between ravens and
browns you know earlier this year and
it's one of those things where i just
look at it and go if cleveland and
baltimore play again because yeah i'm
like you i picked baltimore last night i
was d they're desperate and i just still
i'm sorry i was a little bit of like i
don't know i gotta see cleveland win one
more of these games before i can pick
them totally i just wasn't but i even
though they lost after this i i all have
no problem picking them from here on out
and if they played the ravens again i
think it's scary for the ravens it's not
a good match up for the way they moved
the ball running and throwing it on that
ravens defense last night
i want to see and i'm influenced by what
happened last night i fully admit that i
want to see round three of brown's
ravens more than i want to see round
three of steelers ravens i think i think
i do too i think i agree there's there's
more to this
this what is it i guess it's just the
new upstart team
we've seen raven steelers for so long
for so many years it's just it is it's
cool to see the two young quarterbacks
go after it and you know they're trying
to establish something and and their
careers and and their legacy so uh it is
cool i'm with you i i think you're right
nick chubb and kareem hunt had a big
night last night nick chubb had 82 yards
rushing on 17 carries 4.8 yards hunt
didn't run the ball as much he only had
six carries for 33 yards but he had six
pass receptions
77 yards and chubb and hunt each had a
pair of touchdowns last night's game was
i think only the third in nfl history
with nine total rushing touchdowns isn't
that amazing the ravens had five and the
browns had four mayfields
hey when he decides to go north south
he can he can move yeah you know he he
had that he had that touchdown at the at
the end of the game that put the ravens
uh or put the excuse me put the uh or
tied the game excuse me at 42 all he he
was awesome with that was that the
touchdown was i think it was a two point
head buy a one was that wait it's a
no it was all this one wasn't checked no
no it was
scored the touchdown that put the the
game at 42 all but yeah mayfield uh
mayfield can move when he wants to when
he has to and it's just a matter of
finding the right balance finding the
right balance in the running game
finding the right balance between run
and pass and uh the the browns have so
much to be optimistic about and proud of
i know i i know that we played the sound
earlier of kevin stefanski saying
they're not extra moral victories and
i'm not interested in a coach who will
say anything other than we're not
interested in moral victories but at the
end of the day they have to feel good
about where they are heading into the
final three weeks unfortunately the loss
makes it much more difficult
to surpass the steelers now essentially
two games back with three to go the
tiebreaker is not going to go
cleveland's way even if they pull the
the split with pittsburgh and beat them
week 17 because the superior division
record will belong to the steelers the
browns have lost twice to the ravens um
but uh i yeah i don't see the steelers
losing to bengals next monday night
if they do that opens the door for the
final two weeks but i'd be stunned if
the steelers continue their two-game
losing streak against a team that's won
two games all year no yeah i mean uh i'm
with you i would be stunned there too um
i don't know if they don't if they don't
catch the steelers for the division it
doesn't really matter we've talked about
that it's not a big deal for home field
advantage or anything like that right
now they're sitting in the five spot
which means they'd have to go back to
tennessee where they just kicked their
butt a few weeks ago so they probably
wouldn't feel too uncomfortable about
that type of matchup as much as you want
to win the division and i understand
that but you know either way
the browns are going to be able to walk
away from the last few weeks of football
even last night it's going to be a
positive you're you're you're a playoff
team and you're going to start to say
wait we're not only a playoff team we
can make moves in the playoffs like
we we can play with the big boys and
maybe win multiple games and get an afc
championship you certainly can
with that offensive line they have i
mean
it's it's it's definitely it might be
the best o line in football i mean we
know what they're going to do they're
going to run the ball and they're going
to run boots and play actions and nobody
really can stop it i mean it's
phenomenal physical group they can
physically dominate you they're really
well coached those two running backs are
insane
and
now what's made them awesome is okay our
run game maybe is not killing it or
whatever else you're over playing our
run game well baker mayfield is very
comfortable in our drop back pass game
and and throwing the ball around the
field too and we're seeing that not only
just off of play action and boots which
we saw we're starting to see last night
drop back pass dice them up a little bit
that was probably one of the big
questions we got about that offense can
they do that when that comes around and
we saw enough last night um you know but
they had that baltimore ravens defense
reeling and you know of course i think a
little bit differently of that baltimore
ravens defense after the last few weeks
and the browns passing game post odo
beckham jr there was a question posed to
chad o'shea the receivers coach and
passing game coordinator over the
weekend about how different is the
offense without obj he says it's not
something he's ever thought about which
would make him the only person connected
to the nfl who hasn't thought about it
he attributes the development of the
passing game to just the fact that the
receivers there who are busting their
butts and working hard chris you know i
continue to be a firm believer that
removing from the equation a guy who is
constantly sucking up all the attention
and putting pressure on the quarterback
to wait for him to get open and throw
him the football that's not a bad thing
if you have other guys you can rely on
and they have other guys that baker
mayfield can rely on from richard
higgins who had six catches for 68 yards
and a touchdown last night don from
people's jones every time i see that
guy's name i think chris berman i
haven't heard this surely he calls him
donovan people's court jones that one's
too easy every time i see that jersey i
think of berman calling him hey people's
court jones but uh three catches for 74
yards uh so they they have got and they
got the ball to the tight ends a little
bit more than you know david and joker
who just is kind of this mysterious
figure a first round pick who still
lingers on the team he had a few uh nice
plays last night and you know baker
mayfield spreading the ball around and
when you have a guy in kareem hunt who
can contribute in the passing game
you have a diverse
attack definitely where there's never a
que there's never a question did jarvis
landry get the ball enough there's never
a question did kareem hunt get the ball
enough with all these guys there's never
a question did one get the ball enough
pre-obj acl tear it was a constant
question is he getting the ball enough
chris that is not a positive vibe for
any football team no i i get that you
know but it's not like odell is the one
having a press conference going i need
the ball more
you know
okay i mean he's we can we can pull
quotes over the past couple of years
because in his mind he wouldn't wait but
he is here we're talking
well but i it was it was percolating he
equates me getting the ball with winning
the thing that was frustrating them this
year is they weren't able to beat good
teams that's what would send him into a
funk he knew the narrative
just as it was getting established they
beat the teams they should they lose
convincingly to the teams that they
should lose to he would feel much better
about where they are right now the
question is the chicken and the egg
would they be where they are right now
if he was playing for them right now
would they have gotten to the point
where they could beat a team like the
titans convincingly right where they
could be where they could be close to a
team like the ravens we don't know we
may never know because by the off-season
they may decide
we are better off moving forward with a
collection of receivers
none of whom
there's ever a question about are we
throwing him the ball enough
he's a lightning rod guy he is even if
he was sitting in the corner doing
nothing he's become the type of star and
spectacle that you know we still write a
story and we go like biggest story of
the day he was sitting in the corner
doing nothing what's wrong with him and
then it becomes a thing like why are you
sitting in the corner and being quiet
what's wrong with you so he can't really
do right but chris he's got blame i know
he has
because he welcomed all that in 2014
after that catch and he became the
flavor of the month like that might as
well be seven
in germany
that's decades like he he contributed to
the transformation of odell beckham jr
into someone who wasn't just a football
player but an icon beyond the sport he
he welcomed it and he loved every minute
of it until the scrutiny came along so
there's a way he could have played this
2014 2015 and maybe he needed better
advice from grown-ups in the room
because he's young at the time i don't
fault him for making decisions that a
young person would make but but the
reality is
we developed this obsession with otto
beckham jr because he welcomed the
spotlight
he bathed in it he basked in it and he
did all those things on the sidelines
and other people don't do like slam your
helmet into the kicking net and it
swings back and hit you in the face yeah
well yeah he's he had some moments we
know that there's no doubt about that i
mean but this year he didn't really have
those moments he's been a team guy since
he's been in cleveland and but i
understand your question you know i do
listen we've talked about it a zillion
times nobody seems more affected by
odell beckham jr on the field than baker
mayfield baker mayfield is the number
one guy i've always said from the start
of last year that looks uncomfortable
with it everybody else seemed fine now
odell you're right he's made his own bed
in a lot of these ways i do think he's
tried to turn the corner and be you know
the team guy do do things the right way
for himself and the cleveland browns and
i think he's been a little unfortunate
here where
you know the offense got its mojo and
maybe it is because without him i mean
maybe it is but i don't look at it that
way i think it's more of they didn't
have an off season like jarvis landry
had said to you and all the like we
talked about before where you know the
offense wasn't hitting at all cylinders
early in the year it was simple it was
all about just the run and there wasn't
a lot to offer you in the past game
they've obviously have a better
understanding of that now i'm one that
sits here and goes no wow i mean man
they what would they look like if they
had odell beckham jr on the field last
night uh i i understand the questions
the other way but i think too with chad
o'shea and mike i'm glad you brought him
up the passing game coordinator
coordinator
quietly one of the best things kevin
stefanski has done in his career because
you know me i complained about his
passing game schematics but a guy like
o'shea with his new england background
now he can infuse a few more ideas into
a passing scheme that i think was kind
of ordinary um but but you know
ultimately
i don't know i'm one that thinks hey if
they had odell out there last night that
could be even even scarier for where
this offense is right now
look we both have a ton of respect for
brian flores but he gave both the giants
and the browns a gift by getting rid of
defensive coordinator patrick graham
after one year definitely and chad
o'shea after one year right yeah uh both
both of those it's it's look you can't
knock the dolphins because they're doing
fine too maybe it is a
win-win-win-win-win
but
uh yeah o'shea and graham both doing fun
where they currently
are hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports